huh okay what'd I miss yeah so I wasn't
able to get to Gotham last week so while
the rest of you all were watching the
Super Bowl I was catching up on two
episodes of Gotham don't worry I'll talk
about the Super Bowl trailers tomorrow
but for right now
Gotham episodes 4 & 5 ruin and Penna
pure I can't remember what it was called
so I'm probably not gonna do a lot of
distinction between one who's over to
the other because I did back-to-back
them so it all kind of blurs together in
my head and obviously I'm gonna be
talking about spoilers here so there you
go with all that so the whole coming off
the explosion of Haven and like making a
big mystery out of it was a little bit
of an odd call like inherently I'm not
entirely sure I buy what they're selling
with this idea that the detonation of
Haven really like brings all everybody
together and they pool their resources
and like Barbara and penguin want to
help I'm like I I guess I'm having a
hard time seeing how the destruction of
Haven brings them together when you know
the destruction that led them to this
entire situation in the first place
didn't do that so I I'm that that was a
hard swallow and also I'm kind of
getting a little bit burned out on Jim
giving speeches to calm down a mob
although it was kind of nice that it
didn't really work when he tries to talk
people out of not trying to kill
Victor's ass Oh Victor I have missed you
oh he's so good oh he's just Oh smarmy
and like they've arrested him they're
interrogating him they slam his head
down on this table boom
you know there's a real nice table like
oh god I love this guy so much oh I
didn't even realize how much I was
missing him then you've got Edie you
know trying to figure out what's going
well Riddler I guess trying to figure
out what's going on because he keeps he
keeps referring to the side of himself
that he doesn't know what's going on has
edge so I'm so presuming it's the
Riddler persona in charge and so they
built a little bit of a mystery around
that well thankfully they don't stretch
it out too much longer because I think
that was starting to push its luck so
now stretching out into this episode we
have well first of all after a really
honestly awesome scene between ed and
Oswald I loved the scene where Edie
confronts him because he thinks Oswald
messed with his head in a very literal
sense and the scene that the two of them
share like how hurt Oswald is like if I
ever want to kill you you will know that
I am your enemy because I'm your friend
and Edie again in this twisted like
solidarity moment just being like if I
ever have to stab you I will look you in
the eye and do it in your heart and you
know penguins got this look he's like I
feel to say wait like oh god yes
oh it's been too long since I've seen
those to share a scene together oh that
was good stuff too and then we in Hugo
Strange back also always welcome and we
find out what's been going on with Edie
and the answer is a little silly
I mean it's Gotham so III buy it terms
of a chip in Ed's head being controlled
by I can't remember what they've named I
mean he's he's bein he's gonna turn into
Bane I'm calling that now which I might
not have called if they had if the
makers hadn't spilled that Bane was
gonna be a thing this season but knowing
that this guy shows up I'm like that's
Bane that's gonna end up being Bane so
pre Bane that's what I'll call him until
he actually gets there you know is is
pulling you know he's pulling the
strings of Ed and he's just acting on
orders and it's a nitpick and maybe like
they couldn't get approval from from
deceive to actually drop this given that
it's got crossover issues with other
things going on with other in other
areas but it really annoyed me that they
kept referring to the to the person that
Jim have been talking to on the radio
and the person who is pre Bane's
commander as Walker I really wanted them
to say Waller like come on your one
letter off just but you know I knowing
that even after they have blatantly set
it up that CW was not allowed to use the
Suicide Squad even even after having set
it up because the movie division said I
know we're doing it and we don't want we
don't want to be doubling up on stuff I
so I wouldn't be shocked if Gotham
wasn't allowed to reference Amanda
Waller but like it would a fit and and I
do have to feel I I can't help but feel
like Walker was their attempt to nod to
who they wish they were getting to use
for that I mean I mean it's a it's a
faceless character but still so not I
would have appreciated Jeremiah is back
and now been stabbed and I he said he's
a little crazier now than he was when we
saw him at the end of the previous
season which is good it's nice to have
things move forward and progress on that
and in terms of how crazy he is because
he was always a little bit too
restrained for me certainly versus
Jerome like and that's kind of that's
the hurdle that I'm very afraid that
Jeremiah is never gonna over
for me I prefer Jerome and the thing is
I feel like I would like Jeremiah if I
didn't have Jerome to compare him to
because he's a pretty decent Joker as a
character but I had Verger own before
and I liked him better and I miss him
and I missed that that wild card nature
I feel like you know in a lot of ways he
they managed to pull off what the
Suicide Squad Joker was trying to go for
just coming across as completely
unpredictable
and I feel like they actually got that
with him with Jerome but Jeremiah feels
the much more calculated and that's
never as interesting a joker for me
especially when he's interacting around
other villains I always think the Joker
works best as this guy's too insane for
anybody to trust like and everybody's
scared of this guy and Jerome felt like
he fit that mold better trying to think
what else
Harvey's had some nice moments actually
especially with Jim Selena's doing
pretty decent and oh this I laughed way
too hard at this line echo sort of the
pseudo Harley Quinn she had a line let's
make like my dad before my sixth
birthday and move out I left way too
hard at that yeah that that just worked
for me random bit there so yes so Selena
and Bruce the push and pull between them
is still working pretty well I find it
interesting that the whole like the seed
for Maivia notes group to Durham brought
outer darkness still hasn't really come
up so right now I'm sticking to my
assessment that it wasn't necessary and
you know they yeah it could just heal
her it didn't have to like turn her bad
because I could buy everything she's
doing just out of being pissed and a
little bit obsessive Barbara Barbara had
a tender moment that was odd like she
couldn't shoot penguin in the wake of
the explosion and that's again that
seemed like pushing at that fed into
that bit that I said I wasn't entirely
sure I bought machine Jim got cozy again
I have to wonder if that's gonna come
into play in some way it better because
otherwise like that was pointless it was
very weird to me that they end
Pepa sewed four on that and it doesn't
come up in Episode five that's a little
odd to me oh so we've got the tease and
I guess this is potential double
spoilers because I'm gonna speculate now
so we've got the tease with Jerome you
know looking at the results of you know
two people and there's a doctor who's
been working on them presumably it's
about appearance because we don't see
their faces and the reference that
Jeremiah makes saying something about a
family reunion my first guess is that
he's had some one plastic surgery up a
couple of people to look like Martha and
Thomas Wayne that's just the first thing
that comes to my mind even if it's not
them it's some family members of
somebody that he gives a crap about who
are dead and given that he doesn't seem
to give a dang about his own family and
he did seem interested in Bruce not to
the degree Jerome seemed to seem to have
been but he does seem interested in
Bruce so like that's that's me guessing
that's my prediction on that and I think
I'll wrap up on that one
it's good it feels good to be caught up
the I'm I'm still waiting for things to
like completely fire on all cylinders
but it's moving forward I'm enjoying it
and I'm and I am getting these moments
that I love like Victor coming back like
ed and Oswalt together and they're
seeing like I am getting these things
and like I get at least one of those per
episode I'm like huh and that's why I
love this show I wish I could have more
scenes and moments and feels like that
per episode that'd be nice but you know
one step at a time
Gotham episodes four and five you've
seen them what do you think about them
whatever your thoughts are drop swimming
down to comments let's talk about a
whole bunch of stuff down there as well
because there's buttons links there's
the patreon it really it's really super
helpful and I'd appreciate it but you
know there's no stuff to check out as
well P o box I got a book Instagram it
all sorts of stuff it's down there check
it out or you know if you don't really
have time that's okay too I won't hold
it against because at the end of the day
you're the council and I just run the
meetings so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]